alors on pense généralement que le
moment le plus important pour vous a été
le moment où vous avez posé le pied sur
la lune est descendu du lem c'est bien
exact où est ce qu'il ya eu un autre
moment beaucoup plus vous avez beaucoup
plus d'émotions
demos eh bien peut-être le moment le
plus difficile en tout cas la partie la
plus difficile de l'ensemble du vol
apollo 11 était en fait la dernière la
dernière descendre la fin de la descente
la surface de la lune parce que
évidemment il ya très peu de
l'équipement en matériel fonctionne et
avait été oubliée pas tous les systèmes
étaient fonctionnels et fonctionnels à
rendement il y avait quand même beaucoup
d'inconnues beaucoup d'inconnues
et puis cette manoeuvre là n'avait
jamais été fait aucun vaisseaux spatiaux
ne l'avait jamais fait par conséquent
c'était une première c'était très bien
si c'était un moment très délicat et en
tant que pilote il faut dire aussi que
c'était le plus grand défi au fond
auquel j'avais à faire face parce que
tout pilote aime bien faire sa joie tout
ça et c'est la partie la plus importante
du vol c'est toujours l'atterrissage en
douceur
et puis c'est tout poser l'appareil au
sol finalement fin c'est le moment de
l'atterrissage qui est le plus important
et c'était vrai aussi pour le lem
bon alors vous vous êtes derrière nous
nous avons une réplique de la lune et
nous avons planté un drapeau américain à
l'endroit où approximatif
oh vous vous est posée mais n'y voyez
aucune malice mais je crois que vous
avez quelque peu raté là le point a
choisi la cible de 2
c'est tout à fait exact
disons que toute une série de
difficultés même qui se sont lancés on a
essayé de trouver le parcours idéal sur
la lune et au dessus de la lune parce
que c'était pas bien connaissions mal
les variations ou au point de vue de la
pesanteur de la lune
les zones les plus sombres de la lune
les maires n'est ce pas mais les mers
lunaires ont une densité plus forte que
les zones avoisinantes sont départis
d'allumer qui sont plus lourdes et par
conséquent l'effet de la pesanteur est
plus important ce qui fait que les
orbites ne sont pas régulières autour de
la de la lune
il s'agissait là d'un connu et c'est à
cause de cela que d'une simple ou pas
n'ont pas atteint exactement là on avait
prévu à marquer on a appris très vite
parce que apollo 12 ha pour le 12 ali
exactement à côté du soleil qui avait
quitté la sonde qui avait été envoyé
deux ans auparavant et alors on a
beaucoup parlé de cette fameuse phrase
que vous avez prononcé qu'on a entendues
dans le film qui s est un petit pas pour
l'homme mais un bond de géant pour
l'humanité
et on sait une responsabilité historique
que de dire une phrase comme celle ci et
on a pensé que vous là que vous la
répétiez un petit peu avant de descendre
parce que les portes du lem mettez un
certain temps à s'ouvrir et en fait ce
n'était pas ça je crois que c'était un
problème de dépressurisation
il y avait toute une série d y ait toute
une série de difficultés auxquelles nous
sommes heurtés après l'alunissage ses
neveux a pris donc un petit peu plus
longtemps et que prévu le problème de la
pression a certainement été un des
problèmes les plus délicats
la dépressurisation et des calmants vrai
vous avez a très bien saisi cela me suis
très bien senti c'est vrai que pendant
ces minutes j'étais en train de me
demander ce qu'il fallait que je dise
finalement cette occasion mémorable
non non c'est après elle et lui sachent
que au fond j'ai commencé à me demander
ce qu'il fallait dire
alors j'ai c'est à ce moment là
cette période d'attenté effectivement
j'ai essayé de trouver quelque chose
parce que c'était un moment inoubliable
souvenir
vous l'avez probablement fait très
souvent mais essayez de vous souvenir la
porte sous vous êtes aidé par aldrin qui
vous aide à passer dans la porte c'est
pas très facile parce que vous avez un
os kfor avec man vous aide il vous guide
on entend d'ailleurs cette conversation
à houston très bien on vous entend parlé
tous les deux la porte sous vous
découvrez
le panorama lunaire et vous commencez à
descendre est ce que vous vous souvenez
de cet instant là à quoi avez vous pensé
oui je me souviens très bien
effectivement cette moment où je
descendais de l'échelle ça me a laissé
un souvenir tout à fait précis la toute
première chose
la toute première chose que je devais
faire au fond mon principal souci était
la première chose à faire était de
d'abaisser la plateforme sur laquelle on
montait le la caméra télévision pour
pouvoir prendre des images
nous ne pensions pas que la télévision
haut fonctionnaire est franchement parce
que nous avions déjà essayé certaines
avons très souvent essayé de faire
marcher cette caméra télévision et nous
n'avions jamais réussi
vissé sur terre a vraiment bien faire
fonctionner cette caméra par conséquent
nous ne pensions pas que l'image sort
est bonne et nous étions à 200 400 mille
kilomètres d'ici cela étant dit les
ingénieurs finalement 2 va tout s'est
bien passé
l'immergeant était bonne mais vraiment
je peux vous assurer que les le plus
étonné c'est elle ou sur la lune futur
vraiment très étonné que ça marche aussi
bien vous avez en france il était à peu
près lorsque vous descendiez de la
l'échelle du lem il était à peu près si
ma mémoire est exact à peu près trois
heures à 4 heures du matin en france et
beaucoup d'entre nous et c'était
milan réveil s'était levé et est devant
la télévision qui transmettait ces
images et je dois dire que ça a été
bouleversant ça a été bouleversant et de
vous voir là ici avec nous cet ex chose
d'extraordinaire je pense que ceux qui
suivent cette émission maintenant
partage ses sentiments et je vais donner
la parole à notre ami d'arbois et
anne-marie d'amaury pour qu'ils nous
transmettent probablement tous les
témoignages et aussi les questions qui
leur sont parvenues et bien là je ne
sais pas si vous voyez ce qu'en quarante
minutes
oui nous avons reçu comme appel nous
sommes un petit peu submergé avec
anne-marie l'amaury je dois dire qu'à la
première lecture très rapide il y a bien
sûr cette question qu'est ce que cela
vous a fait de marcher sur la lune
il y a 2 de legend très forte que nous
retrouvons sur énormément de fiches ce
sont les troubles psychiques qu'aussi
bien monsieur armstrong que ses
compagnons d de son vol ou d'autres vols
ont ressenti après leur voyage
et puis alors la grande question des
rencontres que ce soit de la vie sur la
lune bien des objets volants non
identifiés
ce sont des questions qui reviennent
souvent je dois dire qu'il y a
énormément de témoignages de sympathie
de bienvenue d'admiration de
félicitations et puis vous parliez alain
tout à l'heure de ce qu avait ressenti
les les humains sur la terre voici un
témoignage
je voudrais savoir si la femme de
monsieur armstrong a eu le même réflexe
que moi dit une téléspectatrice car lors
de l'émission en voyant neil armstrong
sur la lune j'ai trouvé cela tellement
beau que j'ai réveillé mon enfant et que
je me suis mise sur le pas de la porte
pour voir en même temps la lune et
l'émission est ce que votre femme a eu
la même réaction monsieur armstrong les
enfants les enfants le tronc suivent ils
ont suivi vos premiers pas où il dormait
non
oui bien sûr il suivait chaque instant
de mon opération et j'ai cru comprendre
qu'ils ont reçu des renseignements très
précis sur ce qui se passait au moment
précis et avec un niveau de confiance
remarquable mise avait confiance en leur
père plus un mac moi oh moi même
d'ailleurs ils sont encore très jeune il
avait quoi
quatre ou cinq ans pour l'année je crois
à peu près et bien le plus jeune le plus
jeune avait 6 ans et l'aînée 12 ans très
honnêtement très honnêtement ils ont été
intéressés il se rendait compte que
c'était papa qui marchait sur la lune
je crois que oui je crois que oui je ne
suis pas tellement certain qu'il se soit
qu'ils étaient tellement impressionné
par si vous voulez ce fait d'armes ou
c'est cet exploit que l'ont été d'autres
enfants et il était peut-être très déçu
que je ne sois pas un grand joueur de
football tout bien réfléchi ni d'autres
questions oui avez-vous vu monsieur
armstrong la terre bleue comme nous
venons de la voir sur la photo
demande-t-on oui oui bien sûr et c'est
je veux le dire un spectacle remarquable
très beau c'est une planète bleue foncée
entouré de dentelle blanche que sont les
nuages d'ailleurs et devant ce fond noir
on voit une image absolument splendide
les photographies vous donnait
d'ailleurs une idée approximative de ce
à quoi cela peut ressembler ayant été là
bas moi même bien sûr c'est toujours
différent de ce qu est une photographie
dans ce cas c'est c'était
particulièrement vrai cette fois ci
le guidon
alors il ya ici des gens qui téléphonent
asvp et qui ne croient pas à l'aventuré
spatiale
il y à un monsieur qui a téléphoné de la
région parisienne et j'ai l'impression
que tout ça c'est un canular que ça n'a
jamais existé
il y à une femme qui va un petit peu
dans la même direction et qui dit on dit
que la lune n'est pas habitée mais
finalement quelles preuves en avons-nous
bon alors je voudrais répondre à cette
date que si elle veut bien me faire
confiance je suis amstrong est avec nous
ici bien vivant et que deux sources
généralement autorisée on s'accorde à
reconnaître qu'il a été sur la lutte des
images du film de la rega et quand c'est
ce sens la teste et puis je crois aussi
les retransmissions qui ont été faites
mais c'est vrai que très souvent on a ce
genre de réaction vous l'avez aussi aux
états unis au cui oui il ya des gens
partout dans le monde entier dans tous
les pays qui soupçonnent toujours leurs
proches un qui pense toujours que tout
le projet était un canular et je
respecte je respecte leur avis bien sûr
est que tout a été monté par les chaînes
de télévision américaines et vous êtes
un très grand acteur alors oui c'est ce
qu'ils croient effectivement bon alors
la seconde question était de savoir s'il
y avait des habitants sur la lune c'est
ça de marie et guy tout à l'heure en
parler un peu odier sur sept est la
question qui revient le plus souvent at
il rencontré des ovnis et on croit aussi
qu'il en a rencontré mais qu'il avait
des ordres absolument formel de ne pas
en parler s'il en avait rencontré donc
toute façon on entretient le mythe non
mais gégé là les journaux de l'époque
c'est-à-dire les journaux de juillet
69 et par exemple le parisien journal
français le 17 juillet 1969 le titre et
la vie existe-t-elle sur la lune
il va percer le secret alors comme vous
l'avez percée des totaux il n'y a
personne sur la lune vous n'avez
rencontré personne est bien comme vous
pouvez aisément l'imaginer
alunir un endroit où comment dirais-je
personnes aucun être aucun homme aucun
aucune femme n'a jamais été auparavant
aucun être vivant n'a jamais été
auparavant
en ce point précis faire cela dit est
une expérience absolument unique en son
genre et elle est irréel elle est
irréelle cette expérience et j'imagine
que j'étais comme de nombreuses autres
personnes dans cette même situation
j'ai pris le plus fort et plus le plus
grand plaisir à avoir quelqu'un ou
quelque chose que je puisse reconnaître
un lapin si vous voulez ou encore un
buisson ou encore une boîte de bière
vides mais il n'y avait plus rien
c'était comment dirais-je un endroit
désole un désert de roche de sable et
j'imagine que pour s entendre ce que
dans une telle situation n'est un
sentiment d'isolement de solitude il
n'en était rien nous avions des liaisons
radio nous parlions avec nos amis qui
étaient sur la terre qui était passionné
par notre expérience parce que nous le
racontions sur ce que nous voyons par la
situation dans lesquels on était et
nous ne sommes pas allés partout sur la
lune nous sommes allés en six endroits
seulement et nous n'avons pas trouvé de
preuve qu'il existe des êtres vivants
mais enfin il ya encore des endroits sur
la lune nous ne sommes pas allés
et pour ceux qui espèrent qu'il y a de
la fille sur la lune ils peuvent
toujours avoir d'espoir jamais vous êtes
vous êtes un scientifique vous êtes un
quelqu'un de tout à fait rationnel donc
vous saviez bien qu'en arrivant sur la
lune vous n'aviez guère d'espoir de
trouver des êtres vivants
effectivement on ne s'attendait pas à
voir quoi que ce soit de vivant et en
réalité il semble que il n'ya pas d'être
vivant dans aucune des planètes dans le
système solaire dans notre voisinage
dans la mesure où nos connaissances ion
de vie qu'on le dise n'avons pas de
preuves de vie de ce genre
ce qui ne signifie pas bien sûr qu'il
n'y a pas de vie ailleurs dans l'univers
mais il semble toutefois que dans notre
petit coin à nous de la création
universel et bien nous sommes les seuls
occupants pour le moment alors est-ce
que vous avez une question qu'on a dû
vous poser probablement de nombreuses
reprises à nombreuses reprises est ce
que vous avez rencontré des ovnis
et si c'était le cas pourquoi ne verriez
vous pas souvent on a signalé qu
effectivement des gens rencontrés des
ovnis à proximité du vol d'apollo 11 et
à propos d'autres vols spatiaux
également eh bien nous avons vu quelque
chose
nous avons eu quelque chose alors que
nous allions vers la lune et c'était il
semble que c'était comment dirais-je un
clignotant une lumière qui clignotait le
long de nos trajectoires les calculs de
sa position nous ont indiqué avait
incontestablement qu'il s'agissait soit
du troisième étage de saturne qui nous
accompagner vers la lune sur une
trajectoire parallèle semblable à la
nôtre
ou alors qu'il s'agissait peut-être de
l'un de ces panneaux provenant de ce qui
se trouve en dessous du module de
commande et qui relie ce module avec le
module lunaire c'est panneaux s'ouvre
cette partie tourne sur elle même elle
est alors relié de cette façon comme
vous l'avez vu sur le film et ses
panneaux ne restent pas fixée ils sont
au bout d'un certain temps
largué éjecté de l'astronef parts dans
l'espace et tournois sur eux mêmes dans
l'espace et eu également nous ont
accompagnés pendant un certain temps le
long d'une trajectoire parallèle alors
un panneau comme celui-ci pas en blanc
qui tournoient qui tourbillonne dans
l'espace qui reflètent de la lumière
solaire peut effectivement donner
l'aspect de cette lumière clignotante
que nous avons vu et je suis persuadé
personnellement que c'était soit une
pièce de saturne le troisième étage de
stature soit ce panneau ci qui était le
seul objet non identifié c'est oublier
que nous avons pu voir
et pour ce qui concerne votre intime
conviction vous êtes il avait été pilote
pendant très longtemps on avait été
pilote d'essais puis vous avez travaillé
avec la nasa bref vous connaissez bien
les problèmes là est ce que vous pensez
qu'il y à des optiques cela peut exister
je suis ce que l'on pourrait appeler un
agnostique en matière d'offre ni ce qui
signifie que je n'y crois pas d'une part
et je ne suis pas contre non plus je
serais ravi qu'on montre un et j'espère
qu'un jour nous verrons quelque chose
qui pourrait nous persuader mais pour le
moment en tout cas
jamais je n'ai vu de preuve indiquant
qu'il en existe et je n'ai pas entendu
dire à partir de preuves qu'ils soient
vraiment irréfutables et qui soit
convaincante qu'il puisse en exister svp
oui il semble pour la majorité de nos
correspondants se soient davantage
l'aventuré humaine que l' aventure
scientifique qui les intéresse et on
vous demande monsieur armstrong quel
était le sentiment qui prime et lors de
votre voyage était un sentiment de
solitude ou au contraire d'encouragement
de tous les peuples de la planète
et lorsque vous étiez sur la lune
avez-vous pensé à la possibilité d'une
panne pouvant empêcher votre retour sur
terre qu'aurait-il fallu faire dans
cette éventualité
et quelle aurait été votre réaction
tout d'abord nous étions fort fort
étonné que tout est aussi bien marché
parce que pendant toute notre de
formation tout avait été conçu
précisément précisément pour faire face
aux imprévus des situations graves et
inattendue et nous avions pensé qu'il y
aurait 15 empoisonnement en même temps
simultanée et par la suite par
conséquent lorsque le seul trouvait
finalement en train de quitter la terre
tout tranquillement pour la lune
et puis au fond pour l'essentiel tout
marchait pas je ne savais pas s'il
fallait que j'en sois très heureux au
contraire très méfiant très inquiète
moi j'avoue que au fond j'avais un petit
peu le sentiment que nous avions
vraiment une chance inouïe le nous trois
nous étions les dans le monde entier et
puis extérieur du monde en quelque sorte
nous étions les plus chanceux parce que
c'est une expérience tout à fait unique
en son genre
même s'il ne s'agissait pas d' ailleurs
d'essayer de devenir j'aurais eu ce
sentiment parce que c'est très
extraordinaire de pouvoir briser le lien
de la pesanteur et et pouvoir à regarder
en arrière en quelque sorte
il faut dire que pendant ces dix années
ces événements sont devenus très
importants pour l'ensemble de la
population de la terre et du lion en
train de vie il va en ces moments
tellement important alors je n'étais pas
inquiet parce que nous savions qu'il y
aurait sans doute beaucoup de pannes
mais nous savions quoi faire et
finalement il ya eu très peu de panne ça
vous intéressera peut-être de savoir que
au cours d'un vol
lunaire classique ben si tout marchait
aussi bien que les choses étaient censés
marché en d'autres termes si on était
conforme aux normes de fiabilité et bien
là on s'attendrait quand même à environ
1000 pas identifiable d'un élément
quelconque au cours du vol mais
finalement il y a eu que une centaine de
panne donc beaucoup moins que ce qui
était prévu que mettant une chose
normale et je crois que ceci est dû au
fait que vraiment tous ceux qui avaient
participé au projet était tellement
passionnés étaient tellement motivé que
un travail merveilleux a été fait qu on
vous posait tout à l'heure et est de
savoir si lorsque vous avez annuel unis
lorsque vous avez passé quelques 2
heures ou un petit peu plus de deux
heures amasser des pierres etc etc
et puis vous êtes remonté vous avait
décollé est-ce que là
à un moment un petit peu émouvant parce
que bon vous étiez correctement posé
tout s'était bien passé mais il pouvait
y avoir un incident et comment at on pu
y pallier en effet que vous dire est
évident que fins et c'était une
véritable préoccupation peut-être pas au
moment même ça faisait des années que je
pense évidemment à ce moment parce que
c'était un c'est une des questions que
j'avais étudié plus particulièrement je
te veux dire que je connais c'est bien
le vaisseau spatial mais je connaissais
surtout le système de mise à feu
permettant à la fusée de quitter la lune
c'était vraiment le sujet sur lequel
j'avais j'avais vraiment planches et ça
a marché comme prévu et je dois
reconnaître que je suis havrais aussi
pour mon collègue base de vous un peu
regretter ce moment du départ nous
aurions aimé passer un peu plus de temps
sur la lune nous avions pas pu faire
tout ce que nous voulions faire quand
même n'avions pas pu parcourir les les
distances que nous avions souhaité nous
n'avions pas pu prendre les échantillons
qu'on aurait voulu prendre donc nous
avons eu un peu le sentiment en partant
que on n'avait pas fait tout ce qu'on
voulait faire
parvin c'est quand même toujours
agréable de rentrer chez soi pas de
prendre le chemin du retour c'est
toujours un moment assez chaleureux et
nous étions bien heureux de rentrer mais
un peu triste de partir tourner ah oui
certainement certains l'a d'abord j'ai
récité un certain nombre de choses là où
j'aimerais voir comment ça tourne alors
vous avez dit lorsque vous conversez
avec le président nixon je crois que
vous aviez le sentiment de représenter
non seulement les états unis ce qui
était tout à fait normal mais aussi tous
les hommes et les hommes de bonne
volonté
c'est tout à fait vrai
c'est un sentiment extraordinaire mans
puissant je peux vous l'assurer 7 est un
sentiment très profond
nous avions il ce sentiment d'ailleurs
tout au long de des préparatifs pour le
vol nous avions nous avait écrit et des
badges en a partout nous avez envoyées à
des des lettres le souhaitant bon voyage
ne s'agissait pas uniquement d'amis de
par le monde des quantités gens que nous
ne connaissions pas nous ont écrit et de
l'avion ce sentiment qu'au fond nous
n'avions pas d'ennemis personnes étaient
contre ce que nous essayons de faire
tout le monde vraiment souhaité la
réussite de notre mission et ça c'est
une situation assez rare
au fond nous sommes assez peu nombreux à
avoir connu une pareille situation et
c'était très chaleureux
non seulement vous mais quand l'insee
sandrine vous avez emmené des objets
qu'on vous avait demandé d'emmener non
seulement des officiels non je veux dire
que la nasa vous avez demandé de
descendre notamment des médailles
commémoratives des cosmonautes
soviétiques par exemple mais aussi des
objets tout à fait personnel qui sont
montés là haut et que vous avez ramené
par exemple
quel genre d'objet vous at on demandé
d'emmener crois que vous n'avez pas
regardé vous avez tous mis dans un sac
pour ce qui nous concerne mais il est
mais le mail et vos amis avaient des
choses qu'ils avaient fait faire des
notamment des petits rameau d'olivier en
or
oui surtout tous les vols chaque membre
de l'équipage étaient autorisés à
apporter un tout petit paquet avec lui
il pouvait mais ce qu'il voulait et
pouvait le ramener tout ça pour ses amis
pour ça son usage personnel et je vais
effectivement un petit à petit paquet
avec moi comme mes collègues
et comme on l'a déjà dit nous avons
laissé un certain nombre de choses sur
place à l'aide des médailles
effectivement pour les astronautes qui
étaient tombés au cours de l'émission
astronautes américains et soviétiques et
nous avions emporté avec nous et ramener
quelques petits souvenirs de notre
propre vol je ne crois pas que qui est
une clichés ici mais sur le
ces bases que vous voyez là il y à
gauche y ait une petite plaque apollo on
se voyait un petit insigne envoie un
aigle qui atterrit sur la lune et c'est
aigle porte le rameau d'olivier
vous montrez pour montrer qu'il
s'agissait d'une mission pacifique et
dans toute l'histoire de l'humanité
c'est peut-être la première exploration
dans l'inconnu sans armes totalement
sans armes
c'était une mission entièrement
pacifique tout ce que vous dites est
tout à fait vrai mais il faut se
souvenir du contexte de l'époque est
tout de même de cette concurrence
extraordinaire entre vous les américains
et les russes qui avaient on l'a vu dans
le film tout à l'heure une petite avance
au départ sur oust et est ce que
justement cette cette opération apollo
11 n'a pas été faite dans un but de
promotion ou de propagande au sens large
du mot oui bien sûr bien sûr c'est
certainement le cas dans les deux cas
d'ailleurs un des camions pour l'union
soviétique comme pour les états unis
partie de l'objectif de la course à
l'espace c'est un train d'utiliser à
l'époque était de montrer
au reste du monde que pas les deux
idéologies avait un fonds technologique
à fond technique mais peut-être attiré
d'attirer d'autres nations à sept leur
mesure de voir c'est certainement vrai
c'est également vrai pour les pouvoirs
publics qui a prouvé n'a programmé en
tout cas ce n'est pas notre objectif en
tant qu' un membre de l'équipage nous
nous essayons simplement d'atteindre
deux objectifs et c'était déjà déjà pas
mal c'était une mission fantastique à
défis extraordinaires objectif commun
n'a jamais vu nous avons la chance de
runes la grande chance d'y participer
mais et pour nous c'était un objectif
entièrement pacifique et c'est tout à
fait remarquable au fond du point de vue
de l'organisation de notre société et de
ce projet ceci est probablement un
merveilleux exemple de la compétition
pacifique entre les nations pour le bien
de tous parce qu'on reviendra tout à
l'heure sur cet aspect des choses et on
verra quelle est la leçon les
enseignements qu'on a pu tirer de ces
vols et de cette course à la lune qu'on
a un petit peu laissé de côté pour des
raisons à la fois
scientifique technologique et aussi des
raisons d'argent ou tout simplement de
budgets dit pour l'instant on peut
répondre je crois à d'autres questions
oh oui nous en avons tellement que nous
pourrions y passer des heures et je suis
sûr que monsieur armstrong éprouvé
autant de plaisir que nous à y répondre
anne marie d'amours il ya une chose qui
surprend ici asvp les téléspectateurs ne
reconnaissent pas en est l'âme strong un
être humain comme tous les êtres humains
on a l'impression qu'il n'a pas eu peur
et c'est un sentiment qui étonne
énormément les gens comment at il pu
aller sur la lune sans avoir peur
presque oui ou non vous avez eu peur est
une autre question est ce qu'après ce
voyage vous êtes resté le même homme
bien je peux pas vraiment vous dire je
ne sais pas exactement comment
d'ailleurs la tablette pourra rendre ma
pensée en l'occurrence mais il y à trois
niveaux
il ya trois niveaux de crin si vous
d'une part la préhension et puis alors
la crainte à proprement parler début la
panique
eh bien on pouvait pas se permettre le
luxe de panique et sari fait jouer
évidemment à toute efficacité toute
possibilité de prendre les décisions ce
qui était vital la crainte la peur c'est
ce n'était pas un très grave danger
parce que nous avions tout de même une
formation très poussée
les travaux préparatoires avaient été
amenés avec énormément de vigueur et de
précision de gestion près par conséquent
à assumer notre mission
alors l'appréhension oui la prévention
là au fond c'est un niveau tolérable de
méfiance si vous voulez c'est quelque
chose de sain je crois l'appréhension je
crois que c'est assez
c'est une bonne chose je peux vous
assurer que ce qu'on avait une bonne
dose dans l'appréhension lorsqu'on se
trouve je vais demander à francis
caillaux de montrer la fusée saturn 5
lorsqu'on se trouve tout en haut de la
fusée installé dans le dans le module
lunaire et que le compte à rebours
commence et que la fusée va s'élancer
c'est à ce moment là qu'on a le
peut-être avant d'être avant que le
compte à rebours soit définitivement
terminée on a la prétention tête non si
voulions non j'essaie de me souvenir je
ne peux pas d'enfants pas tellement
d'appréhension à ce moment là juste
avant le départ je vais vous dire
pourquoi je dis appréhension parce qu'il
ya eu des accidents malheureux chez vous
à la nasa
il ya des gens qui ont brûlé oui bien
sûr mais quand même à ce stade j'avais
eu un certain nombre de lancements avait
parfaitement fonctionné à 35 nous
savions que ça marche très bien par
conséquent est tout à fait un rôle à bas
service il ya une petite tour car sans à
beaufonds 1,8 pétrole avec le pit fusé
tout à fait à roux qui a en cas de
mauvais fonctionnement en cas
d'explosion en cas d' incendies alors
cas de difficultés pourraient pas fait
pour lui permettre d'écarter à ce
moment-là retourner en parachute sans
mal
ça faisait partie et du de la posture de
vols que nous connaissions très bien de
gestion très très bien très bien formés
à lui dit tu vois pas du tout inquiète
donc l'appréhension ce n'était pas
tellement assez à ce moment là c'est
dans d'autres secteurs du vin dans
l'autre particulièrement à la descente
l'alunissage voulait et puis alors le
départ quand on a quitté la lune
et puis le rendez vous alors rendez vous
avec le module de commande et puis à
l'image de lamar hd2 et des deux
vaisseaux et puis alors le ré entré
l'entrée dans l'atmosphère terrestre qui
est toujours une difficulté pas
tellement parce que nous ne savions pas
ce qui nous attendait non c'est pas ça
mais que si quelque chose ne marche pas
on a plus de temps pour en parler o pour
réparer quoi que ce soit c'est trop tard
mais pour aller un peu plus loin dans la
question qui vous est posée ne pense pas
que dans notre cas il s'agissait d'une
d'une peur physique ou d'une
appréhension physique mais plutôt la
crainte en techniciens de rater quelque
chose de ne pas réussir
l'amarrage ou de ne pas réussir
parfaitement la descend en plomb c'est
plus c'est plus ce problème là parce que
c'est intéressant d'en parler vous avez
subi les uns et les autres à
l'entraînement extrêmement intensif vous
nous ont parlé tout à l'heure
donc ces problèmes de 2,2 peur je crois
n'existe guère chez des gens comme vous
qui en plus on est tous venus de
l'aviation vous étiez vous-même pilote
d'essai sur x 15 enfin bref vous aviez
fait des choses au moins aussi difficile
que celle ci mais c'est peut-être la
crainte de ne pas réussir
techniquement non oui peut-être
peut-être enfin je veux l'être a pas
tort mais ce sont bien évidemment le
plus grand échec possible n'est ce pas
d'où nos précieux ne pas parvenir à
exécuter les missions l'instant était
rien n'aurait été pire
il est également vrai que les avions
qu'en tant que puis le décès nous avions
quand même un sérieux entraînement et
bien sûr l'habitude quand même de
travailler dans des situations un petit
peu dangereuse et c'était notre métier
est de continuer à voir ce qui se
passait à prendre des observations à
noter tout ce qui se passait non pas
nous le permettre il notre état mental
ne pouvait pas nous empêcher de faire
notre travail
c'était très important et nous avions un
peu l'habitude de cela mais j'exagère
peut-être un peu remarquer en disant
cela il est possible que des gens sans
le même entraînement aurait put faire le
travail remarquablement aussi on vous a
posé la question de savoir si vous
considérez au jour d'aujourd'hui après
7,7 première lunaire
ce que vous considériez que vous étiez
un homme différent d'avant avant le 21
juillet 69 ou est ce qu'ils vous ont
accompagné bien sûr lorsqu'on a vu la
terre de la lune on change et puis quand
je crois que oui je crois que tous les
genres tous les équipages de vol qui ont
eu l'occasion un moment ou un autre de
voir la terre d'une distance extrêmement
grande ont vu leur façon d'envisager les
choses différemment
ils sont en présence d'une perspective
nouvelle
une perspective particulièrement
puissante si vous voulez qui ne sera
plus jamais effacer de l'esprit et par
conséquent ces gens voient leur esprit
se modifier en bien d'ailleurs
et j'espère simplement que à l'avenir il
y aura beaucoup de personnes du monde
entier et surtout j'espère des chefs
politiques qui auront la possibilité de
voir la planète de loin de prendre du
recul d'à d'appréhender cette
perspective je ne pense pas que cela
mais beaucoup changé en profondeur sur
le plan humain sur le plan personnel
peut-être ne suis-je pas bien placé pour
parler de moi même et pour juger de cet
état de choses peut-être que je serai
beaucoup mieux jugée par autrui des gens
qui m'ont connu il ya vingt ans de sly
qui me connaissent aujourd'hui
toujours est il que à mon avis personnel
j'ai l'impression d'être le même
exercice extrêmement difficile cinq ans
qui consiste à parler de vous même bien
entendu cela dit vous venez de nous dire
que vous aviez une vie
lyon différente des choses et que par
exemple un certain nombre d'hommes
politiques pourraient aller dans
l'espace et ça leur ferait du bien en
quelque sorte c'est ce que vous vouliez
dire qu'elle est là quelle est la vision
différente que vous avez acquises
une philosophie différente
peut-être
demong de nombreuses personnes
pourraient penser comme je le fais
moi-même que lorsque l'on regarde la
terre de très loin et qu'on voit à quel
point les petites minuscule dans les
cieux on peut danser moment avoir le
sentiment que il s'agit d'une partie de
l'univers qui est somme toute tout à
fait secondaire tout à fait petit sans
importance mais personne n'a éprouvé ce
sentiment parmi les membres de
l'équipage avec lesquels j'ai bavardé et
le sentiment général
la conclusion que nous en avons tous
tirés c'était exactement le contraire
que parce que les petites
parce qu'elle est si éloignée la terre
prend tellement d'importance pour nous
et qu'elle est une chose tellement
fragile qu'elle exige le meilleur des
efforts que nous pouvons les uns et les
autres déployés pour la protéger parce
que à partir de maintenant c'est le seul
foyer confortable que nous ayons tous et
il faut faire de notre mieux pour la
s'ouvrir pour le sauvegarder les épais
et bien nous nous intéresserons
maintenant aux modifications qui ont pu
être apportée est d'abord savoir si
monsieur han chang si vous avez eu des
effets secondaires au niveau de votre
santé
si des études avaient été faites avant
et après votre voyage et si des
modifications été constatée des
modifications psychologique que
physiologique pardon il ya eu des
modifications dans l'organisme
à la suite de ces vols spatiaux et plus
particulièrement à la suite de ce que
nous appelons la pesanteur
ces modifications se manifeste de
diverses façons elles sont assez
semblables dans une certaine mesure à ce
que ressent un malade hospitalisé alité
pendant assez longtemps et les
changements qui interviennent sans du
pour leur plus grande partie à la
pesanteur qui crée un sentiment
particulièrement confortable et agréable
pour l'organisme puisque il n'a plus le
sentiment d'un phare doté d'une charge
supportée par l'organisme et en
conséquence le système cardiovasculaire
d'autres organes deviennent paresseux
ils n'ont plus envie de travailler ils
n'ont pas travaillé suffisamment
durement et au fur et à mesure qu'ils
deviennent part et ceux qui ne
travaillent plus suffisamment il
symbolise et ceci signifie que les
cosmonautes les astronautes doivent
travailler davantage plus fortement pour
s'exercer pour s'entraîner pour tromper
leur sang pour que leurs muscles soit
entraîné convenablement de façon à ce
que cette atrophie soit évité et c'est
modifications semblent tout à fait
réversible une fois de retour sur terre
au bout de quelques jours
au bout de quelques semaines nous avons
totalement récupéré nous sommes revenus
à la normale et ceux ci s'est avérée
exacte même après de très longues
périodes dans l'espace
quoique plus sera long le vol spatial et
je sens entre autres à l'expérience de
nos collègues soviétique et notre
expérience de skylab plus disait le vol
spatial est lent et plus ses
caractéristiques ses symptômes de
modifications seront marqués oui mais
vous dites qu'elle
au bout d'un certain temps il ya un
retour à la normale est ce que est ce
qu'au jour d'aujourd'hui dix ans après
vous subissez toujours des examens de
contrôle par exemple pour voir s'il y a
des transformations quelconque au niveau
physiologique
oui oui oui bien sûr cela fait partie de
notre programme et nous devons être
examinés médicalement chacun des membres
de l'équipage subi un examen médical
une fois par an les données sont cumulés
nous pouvons ainsi disposer dit disposer
de l'anamnèse de chacun des membres et
savoir si ces renseignements se
corrobore s'ils sont imputables
l'expérience soit pendant les
préparatifs soit pendant le vol
proprement dit et jusqu'à présent je
sais pertinemment qu'on n'a pas trouvé
de corrélation de ce genre mais
peut-être y en aura-t-il chez aucun des
astronautes
non seulement chez vous mais chez tous
ceux qui ont participé aux différentes
missions apollo
on n'a pas trouvé de de changement
durable
pas à ma connaissance c est au niveau et
au niveau psychique au niveau mental si
vous voulez parce qu'il ya eu des
changements des problèmes et bien ça
c'est un peu différent
la situation est quelque peu différente
nous avons
connu un certain nombre de romans
dirais-je de 2 2k psychique quelques-uns
disons des difficultés psychologiques
qui sont apparues néanmoins nous ne
sommes pas au clair tout au moins à ma
connaissance sur l'origine de ces
situations
est ce le résultat du vol spatial lui
même il semblerait plus
vraisemblablement que c'est le résultat
des pressions qui se sont exercées sur
le sol sur terre après le vol et vous le
savez l'organisme est soumis à un
certain nombre de pressions qui
s'exercent et tout cela est
caractéristique bien sûr de toutes les
personnes qui ont vécu ce genre
d'expérience vous parlez de quel genre
de pression je songe hélas je ne sais
pas à des demandes de toutes sortes qui
vous sont adressés on vous demande de
participer à tel ou tel programme à
telle ou telle émission à telle
entreprise de bienfaisance on vous
demande de répondre à d'innombrables
lettres à des appels qui émane des
universités des akan amis des académies
des organismes religieux d'entreprise de
bienfaisance comme je les dis
d'industriels et il faut tenir compte de
toutes ces pressions qui s'exercent sur
la personne
que sont devenus en général et les
astronautes que de que font-ils
maintenant ils ont quitté la la vie
active si je puis dire d'astronautes
proprement dit vous par exemple vous
êtes professeur dans une université à
cincinnati et les autres que font-ils
vinet ils ont quitté la halle
il ya encore un certain nombre qui
continue à travailler avec l'agencé john
young par exemple était à mes collègues
dans la même case d'astronomie il était
astronaute de la même promotion il est
venu à houston en même temps que moi
le commandant du premier vol de navette
sera probablement ce garçon cette année
en fin d'année ou peut-être au début de
l'année prochaine
il ya un certain nombre de personnes
comme rnb par exemple fait partie du
programme qui sont toujours à la chance
d'autres sont partis vers d'autres
horizons professionnels le plus grand
pourcentage d'entre eux travaillent dans
l'industrie
en règle générale comme directeur
généraux comme cadre supérieur dans
différentes entreprises
quelques-uns sont revenus au service
militaire dans la vie militaire est ce
que vous êtes généralement des gens
considéraient ce que vous avez
l'impression d'être un homme important
aux états unis
je crois que on nous considère comme des
gens qui ont vécu
si vous voulez une occasion
extraordinaire exceptionnel et la
plupart des gens ont le sentiment que le
programme a été mené à bien avec succès
convenablement et que nous tous qui
avons participé avant une autre on a
joué il existait et la existait beaucoup
d' enthousiasme surtout parmi les jeunes
et je suis très encouragé par ce
sentiment par ce fait qu'il y encore
beaucoup de jeunes qui s'intéressent
beaucoup aux activités spatiales
les jeunes vous le savez un sentiment de
tout enthousiasme ils veulent participer
à quelque chose pense que l'espace
apporter à notre avenir et je crois que
c'est un raisonnement parfaitement sain
tout à fait valable cela doit nous
inspirer
et si je pas une réaction qui fort bonne
est incontestablement les astronef de
demain auront besoin de jeunes
enthousiastes de ce genre pour faire le
travail en question
svp peau des modifications est-ce que
les astronautes ont eu des enfants après
leur retour sur terre
la réponse est oui
[Musique]
plusieurs
hajek des votes par exemple c'est un
exemple qui me vient tout de suite à
l'esprit
il a eu à l'enfant après le vol et bien
sûr dans l'union soviétique
allez petit d'intérêt jusqu'au va on
sait très bien que lesquels elle a eu
elle a eu l'enfant de l'espace vert
c'est elle qui a trouvé cette formule
est à ma connaissance les enfants se
portent bien ils sont les enfants tout à
fait normaux autre chose d'apollo 11
s'entendait bien on nous parle de la
frustration que collins a dû éprouver
alors que ses deux compagnons ont marché
sur la lune et que lui n'a fait que les
recueillir les ramener sur terre
pourquoi est ce que monsieur armstrong a
été choisi et est ce que le second sur
la lune n'a pas lui aussi été frustré
j'ai eu une conversation avec sur
collins et je ne crois pas franchement
qu'il est eu le sentiment ce sentiment
de frustration au moment où il tournait
un orbite autour de la lune c'était d'un
responsabilité de la plus haute
importance
il était il était tout seul sans aucune
aide possible
il était derrière la lune une partie du
temps la plus grande partie du temps
sans aucune communication
il avait appuyé t avais saut très
complexe tout seul il avait un grand
nombre de fonctions à remplir toute une
série d'expériences a fait apprendre à
toute sa cagnotte
c'était un travail extrêmement important
une partie intégrante et vitale de la
hat de la mission et pas seulement de
ceux collins mais le pilote du module de
commande dans chaque vol à une cette
responsabilité très importante
et parmi ceux qui étaient à chacun
d'entre nous avons eu le sentiment que
nous faisions un travail et que tous ces
tâches étaient d'égalé importance en ce
qui concerne la question vous avez
posées au sujet de qui devaient
s'imposer
ok sur la lune la première fois là
c'était une considération purement
technique qui a joué il se trouve que la
meilleure solution la solution la plus
sûre la meilleure solution techniquement
et la solution qui a été retenue il
n'existe pas de savoir lequel des deux
devait le faire c'était juste et de
concevoir le la procédure
ça faisait partie d'un tout la procédure
était conçu précisément pour offrir les
meilleures garanties de sécurité
et apparemment nous avons d'ailleurs
fait ce qu'il fallait faire parce que la
même technique a été utilisé la même
procédure en cours de tous les vols
subséquents n'a jamais modifié la
procédure parfaitement pu admettre que
aldrin descendent avant goût s'est fait
envisageable on la vit d'ailleurs essayé
la première fois mais ça ne marche pas
très bien c'est pas très satisfaisant
que devenait très très difficile très
d'ici là exécuté à notre avis à
présenter un danger parce que ça
signifie qu'il fallait en fait changer
de position à l'intérieur du gros party
banc avec lesq à ford sous pression et
on a essayé plusieurs fois c'était
d'ailleurs notre plan initial et nous
allons finalement renoncé à cette
manière de faire nous avons donc à
verser lors des facteurs et
contrairement à ce qu'on a pu dire
il s'agissait pas de savoir qui devait
sortir le produit sa vie c'est de voir
que techniquement quelles étaient les
meilleures solutions comment un équipage
comme apollo 11 et il choisit comment
fait on pour décider qui doit vivre
ensemble s'entraîner ensemble et caetera
et voler ensemble est-ce que
là encore ce sont les considérations
techniques qui font qu'ils font autorité
ou est-ce que ya éventuellement un choix
de votre part
les deux sont un peu vrai mais il n'y a
pas tellement le choix enfin vous allez
voir le nombre de l'équipier possible et
etat c est assez limité parce que pour
chaque vol
il fallait trois personnes à bord avant
un équipage à l'équipage de secours et
puis à l'équipage soutien ça faisait
neuf personnes neuf personnes pour
chaque mission et à chaque fois il y
avait toujours en plus ont préparé à
chaque instant trois vols ça fait donc
27 personnes chaque instant et à
l'époque 27 c'était à peu près tout ce
que nous avions guerre d'effectifs
supplémentaires
par conséquent nous étions à peu près au
maximum de nos possibilités sur le plan
des effectifs de toute façon au moment
où le l'équipage et est affecté un vol
le lait le but l'objectif du vol n'est
pas encore tout à fait déterminé et ça
c'est une chose que les gens ne savent
pas toujours par exemple en ce qui
concerne apple aux bases et je n'ai moi
même nous avions fait partie de l'équipe
de soutien de secours plutôt pour apollo
8 c'était le vol autour de la lune en 68
vous souviendrez et des ailes a tout de
suite après ce vallon nous a demandé si
on voulait nous a participé à pas le 11
parce que il y avait personne d'autre
finalement 1 pouvant le faire
et lorsque nous avons donc accepté cette
responsabilité à l'époque pour apollo 11
donc plus tard on ne connaissait pas
quel serait l'objectif à duval apollo 11
au moment où nous avons été infectés
apollo 11 nous savions absolument pas
qu'elle nous avions à l'uni
parce qu'elle n'est pas que le module
lunaire n'avait jamais elle n'avait
jamais volé n'y avait jamais eu
d'opération de rendez vous il y avait eu
un vol vers la lune c'était apollo vide
c'était le sol
il y avait des quantités de choses à
mettre au point avant d'atterrir sur la
lune
il y avait beaucoup de choses à faire
encore par conséquent il y avait
énormément d'inconnus alors il se trouve
que c'est tombé sur nous si vous voulez
cet apollon ou apollo 11 qui était le
vol pour la nuit sage mais ça aurait
très bien pu être un polo 12 ou à palau
xiii est un moment où la nasa a affecté
les les équipes apollo 11 ans dans sa
ville exact de dire que justement si
vous avez été si votre vol a été choisi
pour alunir c'est parce que il y avait
on vient ce que je disais tout à l'heure
une certaine concurrence avec las
l'union soviétique et que le retard
était assez sensible de la part de la
nasa et qu'il fallait un petit peu
accéléré les choses et je crois que le
responsable des vols n'étaient pas au
départ
bien entendu au départ moment où on a
décidé l'opération apollo 11 il n'était
pas tout à fait optimiste
il pensait que vous ne seriez pas prêt à
temps pour faire cette opération
c'est exact vous avez tout à fait raison
l'objectif avait été définie
publiquement par le président kennedy
on savait qu'on allait essayer de poser
un homme sur la lune et le ramener sur
terre avant la fin de la décennie à la
fin de la décennie 1970 c'est nous
étions là en 1969 et ça commençait à
vous n'y avez pas énormément de temps
quand elle est allée vite et ainsi
moment là nous n'étions pas en
concurrence directe avec les soviétiques
nous étions en train d'essayer de battre
valence
tu es notre propre engagement quelque
sorte avions dit qu'il fallait le faire
avant la fin lt les années des années 60
et sa certainement d'exercer une
influence sur le choix de l'objectif il
vole on se dit qu'il fallait vraiment
essayé d'alunir le plus vite possible
avec le moins de vols possibles pour
pouvoir respecter l'engagement est bien
dans toutes ces fiches il est difficile
de se retrouver mais il y un point
effectivement qui intéresse les
téléspectateurs c'est de savoir quelle a
été très exactement le rôle de l'homme
dans toute cette opération
on demande s'il était vraiment
indispensable d'envoyer des hommes sur
vesle sur la lune ou si des appareils
n'aurait pas suffi on demande même si un
enfant de 8 ans pourrait supporter ce
voyage sur la lune
oui on en vient ce que vous disiez tout
à l'heure vous avez dit l'ami l'aspect
le plus dangereux le plus difficile
c'est le moment où vous descendez avec
le lem vers la lune vous allez vous
poser c'est la première fois personne
n'a jamais fait ça c'est vous qui êtes
aux commandes
est ce que vous ne pensez pas que les
ordinateurs de houston aurait pu poser
le même sens vous
comme vous le savez l union soviétique
et les états unis ont posé des sondes
des vaisseaux spatiaux sur la lune sur
la planète mars et cetera
les quantités de vaisseau non habité
je crois tout simplement possible par
conséquent cela est ce qu'il est
certaine martel possible disons que ce
vol vol
applause n'aurait pas pu fonctionner
sans homme parce que je n'avais jamais
été conçu pour cela techniquement ce
n'était pas du tout prévu il fallait
donc à l'homme il fallait eu des hommes
parce que les hommes faisaient partie du
dd procédure dès la conception même de
la mission ont par conséquent apollo
était un programme comportant la
présence d'hommes c'était absolument
indispensable et qu'on conçu ainsi alors
il est vrai aussi à que des sondes ont
atterri automatiquement
j'aimerais pas beaucoup être passager
d'un tel véhicule nous cache pas avec un
système de commande complètement
automatique parce que le
l'appareil automatique doit se
débrouiller avec ce qu'il a si vous
voulez et l'homme au fond on
n'accepterait pas cette mauvaise qualité
d'atterrissage ce musculation parfois
très dangereuse
donc si une sonde atterri et puis il ya
un pied dans un cratère et l appareil
bascule et bien bon tant pis mais paul
homme se serait absolument thénac c'est
pas parce que ça veut dire qu'ils ne
pourraient plus repartir vers la terre
et puis il ya un mais il y en plus tout
l'aspect tout l'aspect de près les tout
l'aspect technique enfin les
prélèvements des pierres des de la
poussière l'observation la mise en
oeuvre des caméras et tout ça qui
n'aurait probablement pas pu se faire
seulement avec des engins automatique
oui beaucoup de choses remarquer que
l'on peut faire payer encore beaucoup
d'autres choses que l'on peut faire que
les appareils ne peuvent pas faire la
guerre je veux dire que nous savons très
bien qu'avant nous y ait des sondes
était parti pour la lune avait posé sur
la lune avant notre relation est
d'ailleurs c'est très bon pour nous de
le savoir parce que l'information assure
grilles ont été très utiles et
d'ailleurs je ne suis pas du tout sûr
que cole aurait pu nous intérêts alunir
comme nous l'avons fait s'il n'y avait
pas eu ce travail préparatoire a parlé
les sondes mais il faut également dire
que les résultats scientifiques de
l'émission du programme apollo
cc
ces résultats sont beaucoup plus
importants que les résultats que l'on
peut obtenir simplement avec deux sont à
la fois quantitativement et
qualitativement a donc au fond il faut
les deux il faut les deux certains et il
faudra les deux dans l'avenir également
continueront certainement utiliser des
sondés sur des sceaux veilleuse qui sont
envoyés en éclaireurs en quelque sorte
le panier précisément et puis ensuite il
y aura des modalités des hommes à bord
pour faire un travail plus complet mais
il ya en plus une
le fait d'utiliser des hommes est de
marcher sur la lune comme vous l'avez
fait vous le premier avec votre équipage
il ya en plus une notion d'universalité
de conquête veut dire qu'on prend
possession quelque sorte de la lune et
c'est important non c'est pas simplement
l'appareil c 'est une nation c'est un os
c'est bien sûr c'est quand même ne pas
atteindre l'objectif c'est important
pour l'homme c'est important pour
l'humanité c'est important pour l'espèce
de se fixer l'objectif est d'y parvenir
pour l'histoire de notre société est une
c'est une longue série de réussie de
réalisation en chaque fois un défi en
aller vers des filles et chaque fois on
parvient à surpasser soi même et au fond
c'est ça la clé même de la réussite de
notre espèce c'est le symbole de notre
réussite et ce sera toujours important
pour l'homme
lorsque ça ne sera plus important
programme assez que l'homme
le ciel sera plus rien dire boire oui je
voudrais je voudrais faire une petite
parenthèse ils arrivent ici énormément
d'invitation à déjeuner ou à dîner pour
monsieur armstrong je ne suis pas sûr
qu'il pourra honorer toutes ces
invitations avant son départ qui doit
être dans deux ou trois jours je crois
vous c'est vrai que vous êtes très
populaire et nous avons même une fiche
d'un écolier qui vous félicite et qui
dit que à la minute même où vous tombiez
dans l'océan pacifique
ils n'essaient il y à un certain nombre
de questions qui viennent sur dieu on
voudrait savoir avant votre départ vous
croyez en dieu et depuis que vous êtes
revenu si ça a modifié quelque chose
dans votre vote dans vos sentiments
religieux
à ma connaissance
l'expérience vécue en matière de vols
spatiaux n'a jamais modifié les
sentiments religieux de qui que ce soit
qui ait volé dans l'espace et je le
répète une âme ans est une question de
perspective peut-être certains d'entre
eux ont-ils modifié leur façon de voir
en ce qui concerne l'homme l'univers les
relations entre l'homme et dieu mais
dans mon cas personnel
j'ai trouvé un très grand réconfort dans
l'ordre des choses dans l'ordre de
l'univers dans la façon et je pense que
la façon d'un autre planète est
organisée dont elle se déplace la façon
dont les événements surviennent les
rapports entre les causes et les effets
apporte des preuves abondantes de
l'existence d'un ordre suprême et
cette tendre suprême indique lui a à son
tour qu'il faut probablement une
intelligence supérieure à toutes les
autres pour l'avoir créé oui monsieur
entrons quel est votre vie quotidienne
aujourd'hui quels sont vos rapports avec
vos élèves puisque vous êtes professeur
d'université avec vos voisins avec vos
collègues
qu'est ce que vous représentez
aujourd'hui j'ai enseigné à l'université
et j'enseigne maintenant depuis huit ans
je prends le plus vif plaisir et
j'estime que l' enthousiasme la vigueur
le sens de l'humour de mes étudiants
sont incontestablement très réconfortant
pour moi j'y prends le plus vif plaisir
je le répète je
j'éprouve du plaisir à enseigner et je
vis à la campagne dans une ferme
je prends le plus grand plaisir à la
nature qui m'entourent j'ai piloté je
pilote depuis ces dix dernières années
toutes sortes d'appareils chose la plus
importante à cet égard c'est le fait que
je me suis intéressé personnellement
avec la corporation qui est une société
qui fabrique de petits avions d'affaires
de petits réacteurs d'affaires est
suivie de la taille du falcon que vous
connaissez en france puisqu'il est
fabriqué en france et j'ai eu l'occasion
de voler en permanence pratique morts
sur une base ponctuelle si vous voulez
pour des cas d'espèce que pour essayer
de nouveaux modèles qui sont
actuellement lancés et je prends le plus
grand plaisir mais est-ce que vous êtes
un homme important je veux dire reconnus
officiellement comme tel est ce que par
exemple
vos collègues astronautes le
gouvernement vous a versé une une
pension ou une retraite avant la lettre
pour honorer votre exploit ou est ce que
vous êtes
comme tous les autres mortels un
fonctionnaire comme à l'autre eh bien je
ne suis pas certain que le citoyen moyen
et un mortel comme les autres est
l'expression qui convient
je ne jouit d'aucun privilège
particulier je ne touchent pas de prime
de retraite ainsi anticiper ni de
pension de la part du gouvernement
néanmoins nous avons été amplement
honoré par le gouvernement et par
d'autres organismes pas tellement si
vous voulez nous rend tant qu'être
humain mais en tant qu'être qui
représentait personnifie le succès d'un
projet d'un et nous avons été en quelque
sorte la représentation de centaines de
milliers de personnes qui ont elles
aussi contribué à ce succès et je
constate que c'est là une chose qui est
largement suffisante
bp oui monsieur armstrong étant donné ce
que vous avez dit des hommes politiques
et de votre propre vision ou de votre
nouvelle vision de notre planète
est-ce que vous n'êtes pas tenté par une
carrière politique de mme angle les
téléspectateurs français
non non ce n'est jamais se toucher je
n'ai jamais été attiré par l'idée de
faire une carrière politique
j'admire ceux qui sont dans la politique
et qui acceptent de telles
responsabilités
honnêtement avec énergie avec vigueur
est indubitablement c'est probablement
l'une des vocations les plus élevés et
les plus hautes auquel on puisse
inspirer
j'imagine que les caractéristiques d'un
homme politique valable c'est la
capacité qu'il doit avoir d'être capable
de juger et de trouver les solutions de
compromis adéquates afin d'arriver aux
solutions les meilleures d'atteindre les
bus les meilleurs mais peut-être suis-je
trop idéaliste pour me contenter de
solutions de compromis et c'est
peut-être la raison pour laquelle je
n'ai jamais été attiré par la carrière
politique
autre question oui on nous demande d
c'est une question qui revient très
souvent si vous êtes franc maçon est la
raison pour laquelle vous avez déposé
sur la lune des emblèmes maçonnique
non non non non je ne suis pas je ne
suis pas formation toutefois je crois
que mon collègue ben lui et formation
autre chose eh bien on nous parle
je ne sais pas si la théorie d'einstein
a été bien comprise mais on nous parle
beaucoup de différence de vieillissement
on demande si les astronautes qui ont
quitté la terre et qui sont restés hors
de l'attraction terrestre on vieillit
plus ou moins vite que les autres
humains est en tout cas monsieur
armstrong une mère de famille trouve que
votre votre voyage sur la lune à arrêter
le processus de vieillissement chez vous
car dit-elle depuis dix ans vous n'avez
pas changé
une mère de famille un jeu n'est pas une
pas une demande en mariage
je crois que vous avez déjà en partie
répondu à ça mais peut-être cette
personne n'était pas aller coûte 10 1
qui avait pas de transformation
mais vous n'avez pas parlé de votre
apparence physique c'est vrai qu'entre
les photos que tout le monde connaît et
que nous avons vu tout à l'heure dans le
film est aujourd'hui il n'y a pas de
différence sauf le fait que vous n'êtes
pas habillée de la même manière mais je
vous remercie vous et la dame française
qui m'a si aimablement dit ces choses
elle a été aussi mal que le sont
toujours les français d'ailleurs et je
suis ravi d'entendre des paroles de ce
genre intense et concerne einstein et
ses prédictions
en vérité il existe deux influences
principales sur le processus de
vieillissement tel qu'il est décrit dans
les relations d'einstein la pesanteur et
la vitesse
dans ce cas ci les deux éléments on agit
de façon diamétralement opposées aucun
influencé l'autre
et s'il ya eu une modification dans le
vieillissement j'imagine que c'est de
l'ordre de quelques fractions de seconde
pour la période en question en tout cas
moi je n'ai rien remarqué de particulier
et je me sens ni plus vieux ni plus
jeune que ce que je devrais être présume
que vous avez l'habitude de vous
retrouver une fois par an ou peut-être
davantage avec votre vos collègues de
vol apollo 11
non
j'ai probablement rencontrer chacun
d'entre eux au moins une fois par an
mike allen se l'est vu plus souvent
parce qu'il se trouve qu'il fit à
washington et moi je ne suis pas très
loin
ou plutôt je me rends à washinton assez
fréquemment beaucoup plus fréquemment
los angeles ou vie basé au je le vois
donc moins souvent mais l'un dans
l'autre je puis dire que nous nous
voyons aussi souvent que le pouvons et
nous bavardons les acteurs de cette
expérience
est ce qu'il y a justement non seulement
pour apollon jeu mais pour les autres
astronautes américains une sorte de clad
d'associations
comme ceux qui non non non pas vraiment
en réalité nul n'y a rien qu'on pourrait
appeler l'association des anciens élèves
ou l'association des anciens de l'espace
l'an passé
la nasa nous a tous invités les anciens
j'entends les anciens les premiers à
revenir à la nasa pour être informés à
propos les opérations de la navette
spatiale
on a l'impression vous écoutant que vous
avez une certaine nostalgie pour ses
années passées pour ce que vous appeliez
tout à l'heure cette fantastique
aventure vous avez parlé des jeunes tout
à l'heure vous avez dit les lorsqu on
vous demandait si vous étiez considéré
vous deviez oui les jeunes considèrent
que j'ai fait quelque chose de bien et
voudrait bien aussi suivre mes traces
mais vous n'avez pas parlé des gens de
votre génération et encore moins des
gens plus âgés est ce que l'espace en
amérique est devenu et moins en moins
que l'a été mais vous donnez
l'impression de regretter un temps
révolu
oui mais oui
j'éprouve de la nostalgie est propre à
lui passé ce furent des années cruciales
pour moi je les années pendant
lesquelles toutes sortes d'événements
survenus à une vitesse vertigineuse d un
défi gigantesque extraordinaire m'étais
lancé nous était lancé et qui
s'accompagne de toutes sortes de détails
techniques à propos de ce projet nous
nous sommes follement amusé vous savez
je me souviens du moment où avec émotion
nous vivions ses expériences et je crois
que il ya de nombreuses personnes qui
n'ont pas été associés à ce programme
qui ont partagé qui partage aujourd'hui
encore cet enthousiasme se souvenant de
ses années et peut-être ont-ils deux
meilleures occasions de moi même
peut-être aurons-nous la semaine
prochaine au moment du retour pour le
dixième anniversaire à washington
aurons-nous dis-je la possibilité
d'entendre certaines directions de ces
gens là cela dit je ne m'attends pas à
ce que tout le monde s'intéresse de
façon enthousiaste à jet continu en
permanence à de telles opérations ou
même où qu'encore que des gens
manifestent une apathie total les
guerres de l'espace tout le monde ne
peut pas s'intéresser à tous et nous
avons tous nos intérêts qui sont
différents nos pôles d'intérêts qui
varient et c'était pour cela qu'il ya du
progrès qui réalisé et je ne serais pas
étonné que certaines personnes me disent
que ce à quoi je me suis intéressé mois
était pour d'autres moins importants que
d'autres opérations je comprends bien
mais la question était d'ordre
politique au sens large du mot si vous
voulez j'avais l'impression en vous
entendant parler que le gouvernement
américain s'intéresse moins à l'espace
qu'il ne s'y est intéressant c'est qu'on
y consacre moins de crédits et que on a
un petit peu freiné parce qu'on a des
choses plus importantes ou considérés
comme plus importante et là il ya un
regret chez vous oui oui dans une
certaine mesure c'est vrai bien que
d'après moi l'importance de la réduction
dans les activités spatiales a été
fortement exagéré en fait c'est beaucoup
moins complet que ce que les gens
racontent vous savez il ya beaucoup
d'opérations qui sont encore en cours
dans le domaine spatial aussi bien
l'union soviétique aux états unis au
cours de ces dernières années les
soviétiques vous savez à envoyer
davantage de vols habités avec équipage
que nous l'avons fait nous mêmes donc
que par le passé toutefois dans un
proche avenir nous allons envoyer une
navette spatiale des activités spatiales
vont reprendre avec beaucoup d'intensité
et les européens eux aussi s'intéresse
de très près à cet avenir delà du space
lab du laboratoire spatial de la navette
spatiale
l' agence européenne de l'espace s'en
occupe nous voyons partout même ici en
france des gens s'intéressaient à ses
opérations tout comme aux états unis
en gros on peut dire que le gouvernement
a été extrêmement actif dans le soutien
apporté à ses activités spatiales
peut-être ne sont elles pas aussi
nombreuses et aussi intense contraintes
existent pour ce qui concerne la lune et
des missions auxquelles vous avez
participé mission qu'elle participe et
on a pratiquement cessé je crois à la
nasa de s'intéresser à la lune on a
considéré qu'on avait fait le tour du
problème et je crois
il y à peu près maintenant deux ans on a
si je puis dire le verbe peut-être
impropre débrancher les appareils qui
envoyait des informations ou la plupart
dans le vrai en effet c'est est ce que
c'est vrai toutefois de nombreuses
données émanant de ces stations sont
encore rassemblés nous y avons des
renseignements scientifiques nombreux
nous avons accumulé les informations
grâce auxquelles les hommes de science
pourront travailler encore de nombreuses
années à l'avenir nous avoir accumulé
des échantillons sur lesquels les hommes
de science peuvent continuer à
travailler dans les années à venir et il
est probable qu'à un moment ou un autre
on verra un intérêt s'éveiller à nouveau
à l'égard d'un retour vers la lune je ne
sais pas à quel moment précis mais à un
moment ou un autre cela se produira
voilà par exemple un échantillon qu'un
des vols ça n'est pas le vôtre
mais un des vols apollo a ramené offert
à la france
ce président nixon qui lui avait offert
en 1973 c'est un petit échantillon de
d'une pierre de lune comme ceux que vous
avez ramassé vous même est ce qu'on a
fait ce qu'on a pu faire le bilan de la
lune certains ont dit c'était une des
conclusions du chine tout à l'heure que
nous avons vu que finalement tout cela
n'avait pas servi à grand chose qu'on
n'avait pas découvert de choses
extraordinaires et que peut-être on
aurait pu s'éviter de dépenser autant
d'argent
paris écoutez on peut dire que le genre
de ce qu'on trouve sur la lune
ce n'est peut-être pas absolument
passionnant en tout cas pas pour un
zoologiste nippo tennis bien sûr pour
l'horticulteur ce n'est pas très
passionnant parcours entre un jeune lui
se passionne pense qu'on a trouvé les
métallurgistes également est ailleurs j
c'est tout à fait passionnant on a
découvert des choses qu'on avait jamais
trouvé sur terre des substances que l'on
ne trouve qu'on a trouvé jusqu'à présent
que soit la lune des minéraux qui y
seront d'être du plus haut intérêt à
tenir pour les opérations minières
l'hôpital au petit mais certainement pas
très commode de d'extraire elle le le
dieu minerais et ensuite la ramener sur
terre mais du sang de la construction de
vastes structures dans l'espace alors là
ça serait parfaitement faisable est
beaucoup moins chère des extraits les
minéraux de la lune
plutôt que de faire venir à tous ma de
la terre et on verra plus tard
évidemment si ce genre de choses est
faisable et si cette prédiction se
réalise
moi j'ai trouvé que c'est tout à fait
passionnant et que les résultats même de
l'exploration lunaire était du plus haut
intérêt je crois que l'on peut dire que
l'on sait maintenant beaucoup de choses
infiniment plus de choses sur la lune
que ce que nous avions il ya dix ans ça
me paraît tout à fait clair et puis tout
compte fait la connaissance
c'est quand même le fondement même de
tout progrès humain je sache il me
paraît parfaitement en est parfaitement
certain qu'à terme cela se révélera
payant de d'innombrables façons
est ce que l'on sait par exemple la
suite des analyses faites du sol lunaire
d'où provient la lune
et si l intérieur de la lune il y a
comme à l'intérieur de la terre un magma
en fusion qui peut exploser et bien
personnellement je n'ai pas encore mon
siège là dessus d'autres ont peut-être
seront peut-être abouti à une conclusion
très abouti à une conclusion mais il
semble assez vraisemblable que la fin la
lune en tout cas l ai jamais fait partie
de la terre vous savez que certains
avaient pensé que que la lune en fait
c'était sur terre là où il ya le
pacifique actuellement mais rien ne
semble étayer et d'après ce que nous
avons ramené étayer ce genre d'hypothèse
alors est-ce que la lune a été capturé a
capturé par la terre à certains moments
dans l'histoire de l'espace et ce n'est
pas exclue je crois que l'hypothèse la
plus fréquente actuellement et que la
terre et la lune ont été créés ou
coalescence des tâches dues à peu près
au même moment et à partir du même nuage
de
de matières qui a formé notre planète
autre chose une autre question y lit ici
deux courants qui se dégage ce sont ceux
qui sont déçus par l'arrêt des
expériences spatiales et ceux qui
trouvent encore un intérêt et avant de
parler de l'avenir
je voudrais savoir si monsieur armstrong
peut tirer un bilan des applications
quotidiennes que toute cette aventure de
l'espace a apporté aujourd'hui la nasa a
tenté l'effort cours des dix dernières
années a tenté précisément de de
divulguer de diffuser toutes ces
informations
tout ce que l'on a pu accueillir
d'ailleurs on connaît un certain nombre
de retomber tout de même de ces vols
spatiaux dans la vie de tous les jours
et la nasa a publié un ouvrage et cette
publication en soi une fois pas dans ce
spin off ce sont donc les retombées de
l'exploration spatiale
c'est un ouvrage qui parle tous les ans
et on y trouve les mille et une manières
dont notre vie de tous les jours a pu
profiter des investissements qui ont été
faits pour
pour l'espace en plus la nasa fournit un
service qui permet de donner des
réponses à des gens qui ont des
questions particulières des questions
qui concernent la mise au point de
nouveaux produits ou une question qui se
pose sur le padd est réel donc on peut
un industriel peut aller voir la nasa
est-ce qu'il ya quelque chose que vous
avez vous fait qui pourrait s'appliquer
à mon propre problème est très souvent
la réponse est positive et ce service de
la nasa a rendu d'immenses services ad
littéralement des centaines
d'entreprises et je pense que ceci
continue à être une partie tout à fait
vitale de l'utilisent d'une utilisation
que l'on fait avant ça fait l'aspect ses
lâchetés pacifique si je puis dire c'est
l'aspect industriel c'est le
développement des technologies grâce à
des crédits à une sophistication de la
recherche
mais est ce que il y a eu aussi est ce
qu'il y avait la volonté d'avoir des
retombées militaire éventuellement je ne
pense pas que le programme apollo en
tant que tel et fournit à grand chose
sur le plan militaire
pour leur équilibre des forces
là sur terre cela dit pouvons tous être
certain d'une chose c'est que la paix
sur terre a très certainement été
influencé par l'utilisation des
satellites particulièrement les
satellites de reconnaissance qui ont été
utilisés à la fois par l'est et l'ouest
les deux blocs et ses satellites ont un
petit peu bien couverts que sur le
développement militaire
la rhétorique de la guerre froide sna
freiner tout ça les élites ont freiné un
petit peu la course aux armements dont
manière c'est ainsi qu'on a pu garder
une sorte d'équilibré quand même
certains éléments de contrôle et de
vérification
alors il faut peut-être remonter quinze
ans en arrière pour bien comprendre
cette idée même 20 ans n'a rien il faut
se rappeler quand même la guerre froide
il faut se rappeler la situation
extraordinairement précaire dans
laquelle nous nous trouvions les uns et
les autres la planète même la planète
terre se trouvait dans une situation
tout à fait tout à fait prêter un réseau
en raison des de la division des nations
est parfaitement concevable que tous
n'avaient plus donné une troisième
guerre mondiale et avec les moyens
explosifs actuelle pas très bien ce que
ce que ça aurait pu donner et même
peut-être l'extinction totale alors je
crois que l'on peut dire que ce qui a
été fait au niveau de l'espace a très
certainement joué un rôle a très
certainement permis d
la sauvegarde et la paix vous avez eu
des contacts avec les collègues
soviétique
oui tout à fait j'ai de bons amis que
vous mangez de quebecor notamment
et ils sont bien voir dans mon propre
pays j'ai eu le plaisir d'aller chez eux
il ya vingt ans une amitié très
profondes entre les cosmonautes
américains et soviétiques
parce que je crois que au fond les
problèmes sont les mêmes et le camus le
joueur de tennis différentes et où des
physiciens différents pays ont des liens
très forts entre eux et bien nous aussi
nous avons des mêmes des hommes
politiques d'ailleurs il ya un espèce de
supra nationaux de supranationalité
n'entre des cosmonautes des astronautes
qui font le même métier qui ont éprouvé
les mêmes risques
oui je crois que c'est le cas c'est tout
à fait le cas c'est vrai est de plus en
plus d'ailleurs au fur et à mesure que
de plus en plus de pays participent à
l'exploration de l'espace cette amitié
se renforcera entre un plus grand nombre
de santé eau santé américain ou au
dessus de ces problèmes de nationalité
du fait de votre séjour dans l'espace
olivier tout à l'heure que vous aviez
une vision des choses différentes est ce
que c'est ça justement je veux dire que
cette espèce de main tendue
pacifiquement en laissant de côté les
frontières et les nationalités dans une
certaine mesure oui dans une certaine
mesure oui je crois que
fabien que la course s est passé mais
sans doute d'intérêts nationaux
c'est certain je crois que les ans -
tout tout tout ce qui s'est produit
depuis a plutôt eu tendance à diminuer
les différences plutôt que de les
accroître
justement à ce sujet un regret est en
sûreté en beauté explique de
téléspectateurs qui demandent pourquoi
on a planté le drapeau américain sur la
lune et pas celui représentant l'onu par
exemple où l'ensemble de la planète
on va pas je ne sais pas exactement
comment les choses se sont produites
la décision n'a pas été prise par mois
la décision a été prise par le congrès
des états unis par le parlement
américain en est durant deux
propositions avaient été faites sur
commande devait procéder et blettes et
décidé que bien qu aucune revendication
l'accompagnait cette mission
revendications indienne est rien le
néant mois le drapeau américain serait
planté là pour représenter le pays qui a
exploré qui a procédé à l'exploration
qui a mené à bien cette expédition est
que en portrait pour des missions est
les drapeaux de tous les autres pays et
ses drapeaux là serait ramenée au un
pays d'origine je crois que c'est ce qui
s'est produit à temps les drapeaux
effectivement des terres a mené avec
différents pays
on ne comprend pas très bien ici que la
nasa qui est un homme qui a une
technique absolument fantastique et pu
faire une bêtise on nous dit ici et j'ai
eu une bêtise tels que ce cas là de nous
tomber sur la tête
alors on en revient à la question que
posait tout à l'heure
que vous posez tout à l'heure le
journaliste patrick poivre d'arvor au
cours du journal qui vous demandaient ce
que vous en pensiez vous n'aviez que tu
un peu de temps pour vous exprimer
je crois qu'il serait intéressant qu'on
revienne sur ce sujet on parle de bêtise
est ce que ça vous paraît très sévère
non je te le jure il serait pas et ce
terme là je serais pas d'accord pour
dire que c'est juste une bêtise non
parce qu'à la bête est une expérience
absolument passionnante et qui a très
bien marché
alors je reconnais accueilli leur est
utile et préférant appeler je réponds à
pas très certainement joué tout fait
pour que l'on prévoit la possibilité de
maintien ce cas la bonne orbite pour que
scalable de ne revienne pas sur tel
c'est ainsi que ce qu'elle a utilisé
pour d'autres missions et la chose
aurait été possible si nous avions pu
maintenir d'ailleurs un programme de
vols habités au cours de ces dernières
années mais ne vont pas tel programme en
cours de vol habité il n'y a pas une
financement nécessaire pour un tel
programme et par conséquent n'ont pas pu
aller rejoindre le vaisseau spatial avec
des atterrages a piloté pour fixer son
ska nab les matins nécessaires pour le
mettre
j ai bien sûr et voilà justement un
exemple de ce que l'homme peut faire et
de ce que la machine ne peut pas faire
nous ne connaissions pas nous ne savions
pas comment procéder de manière
automatique
alors il me revient faire il y à il y a
encore dans votre dans votre brevet
presque
un reproche presque un reproche on l'a
arrêté et vols habités si on les avait
pas arrêté on n'a rien on aurait pu
peut-être changer la trajectoire et
gardait skylab sur orbite
c'est un petit peu reproche non oui
enfin si vous voulez à 20 je suis peu
mais toujours pris que disait très
vigoureusement la poursuite d un des
vols des vols habités toujours été
favorable à un programme soutenu
je suis certain que ça rapporte beaucoup
plus que ça nous coûte
cela étant dit je ne voudrais pas du
tout que vous pensiez que j'estime que
jusqu'à l'absurde dangereux je ne dis
pas non plus que évidemment il est
possible
un accident est toujours possible mais
statistiquement franchement la
probabilité d'une rechute avec des
conséquences graves est très très très
faible cette probabilité est très faible
après tout il ya énormément d'objets
créés par finn tous les jours à la
surface de la taille des médias des
météorites naturel et qui peuvent
parfaitement faire beaucoup de mal à
quelqu'un en calabre mais on n'entend
pas tellement parler de ce genre de
choses vous savez quand on est en plein
dans l'actualité est tout à l'heure vous
avez donné une information mais vous ne
l'avez pas donné tout à fait
complètement auto - n'a pas été
interprétée complètement vous avez dit à
m à mon avis à mon avis les probabilités
font qu' il n'y a guère de danger car
scalable devrait tomber dans
l'atlantique sud
bon et vous devez donner une heure vous
avez en principe vers demain soir vers
18 heures deux minutes près c'est
l'heure de paris dont vous parliez
oui c'est en tout cas la prévision la
plus précise
jusqu'à actuellement n'est pas comme
vous vous en doutez
comme vous savez les des prévisions se
fondent manière qu'ils continuent chaque
élément d'information de poursuite de
skylab est entre un ordinateur et
qu'elles se font et on prévoit
exactement la délibération la
dégradation de de l'engin et pour ça
fait plusieurs big maintenant d'après ce
que je comprends de ce dernier que
j'avais reçu un
on prévoit toujours à peu près la même
heure c'est à dire six heures 6 heures 2
demain soir 18 heures heure de paris
10h30 heure de paris mais quelque part
ça tombera dans l'océan assis dans
l'atlantique sud
alors cela ne signifie pas qu'il était
possible que ce soit plus tôt par deux
orbites près en vérité pas tellement
leur qui est importante c'est l'endroit
oui mais il s'agit de prévoir se passait
dans le problème il s'agit d'essayer de
prévoir le ce que veut donner à la
roulette n'est ce pas une fois que la
ville était lancée ça tourne
et puis il ya un ralentissement de la
bille qui qui rejoint d'ailleurs une
autre l'autre outil tourner dans l'autre
sens aussi le problème sur l'orbité est
fixé dans l'espace et individus et plus
au milieu il ya une autre petite roue
qui tourne ça la terre est il celui de
savoir où ça va tomber
alors lequel est soit à peu près l
orbite mais nous avons pas exactement à
quel moment ça tombera sur la petite
route et par conséquent nous ne savons
pas sur quelle numéro 1 au numéro
sortira
voilà le problème c'est ce genre de
problème qui se pose actuellement
however gens de leur âge et cela étant
dit enfin soyez sûr d'une chose c'est
l'unité de travail tout à fait au
sérieux et ils font vraiment et tout ce
qu'on peut humainement faire ça chez lui
cela dit je deviendrai instamment que
les téléspectateurs ne soit pas acquis
moi je suis pas inquiet vous voyez je
suis sera alors soyez le aussi les
probabilités de l'impact dangereux sont
vraiment seule fille mais nous pouvons
être un double gens qui mourront dans un
accident d'automobile demain que du fait
escale sur le tronc se il y à un point
qui passionne les électeurs
presqu'autant que votre aventure sur la
lune c'est votre entraînement
on demande s'il a été très dur comment
il s'est passé et surtout si vous avez
été non seulement entraîné physiquement
mais préparer mentalement et de quelle
façon c'est bien l'ombre d'un équipage
nous avons je vais vous laisser parler
mais nous je voudrais qu'on nous
présente un petit film qui a été tourné
aux états unis au moment de
l'entraînement ça n'est pas votre
entraînement bien sûr mais c'est un
entraînement de d'astronautes peut-être
en reconnaîtrez vous certains il ya
d'ailleurs des femmes dans l'équipe
est-ce que quel était le pourcentage des
femmes à l'entraînement ça devient bon
moment et oise - où il est aujourd'hui
mais il n'y avait pas de femmes dans les
équipes recherchent des gains sur
n'était pas interdite bien sûr une petit
pas question d interdire la venue a été
qualifiée tout au moins pas jusqu aux
expériences les plus récentes et ceux ci
il y a un an et demi de cela vous êtes
contre les femmes dans la main des vols
spatiaux
non pas du tout je pense que nous
appelons des services particulièrement
précieux elle peut faire de l'excellent
travail et elles sont tout à fait
qualifie pour un certain nombre de
tâches la gentillesse de commenter voilà
les femmes en question très jolie
d'ailleurs
et les voici à l'entraînement je vous
laisse nous expliquer ce qui se passe
eh bien je n'avais pas vu ce film
particulier précédemment quant à moi
mais ceci est en rapport je crois avec
un entraînement parachutisme et un
entraînement pour le moment où l'on
touche où ils ont amerri la survie à la
surface des océans
ce n'est pas tellement une un
entraînement pour parachutisme est
plutôt un entraînement à la survie des
hommes et des femmes d'équipage
en cas de situation sérieuse au moment
où ils jamais rice et si vous voyez par
exemple cette jeune femme ces deux
jeunes femmes plus exactement qui sont
sur 1,38
c'est un appareil supersonique et nous
avons constaté que la discipline exigée
pour piloter des appareils à réaction et
pour voler dessus était une excellente
discipline voici la paille qui veulent
en paraboles et qui donne aux occupants
la possibilité de s'habituer à la
pesanteur à éprouver cette sensation
cette sensation est extrêmement
rapprochés et donne à tous la
possibilité d'apprendre ce qu'ils
doivent faire
à s'habituer à ce sentiment cette
sensation d'apesanteur dans un astronef
et puis ceux ci on le voit également
sous l'eau où on l'attend on
une personne qui a été munie d'un
scaphandre et qui est en position de
flottaison si vous voulez et dès lors
que les mouvements sont suffisamment
courts suffisamment lent suffisamment
bref c'est très semblable au mouvement
que l'on ferait si vous voulez en
position d'apesanteur dans l'espace vous
avez suivi le même entraînement j'ai
fait ce genre de chose c'est des pourris
en fait
oui en réalité l'entraînement sous l'eau
est intervenue plus tard et je les subis
pendant les deux dernières années de mon
entraînement
dix hommes d'équipage
et c'est une femme d'entraînement qui
est de plus en plus populaires parce que
les durées sous l'eau peuvent être
extrêmement longue et on a conçu tout un
ensemble de systèmes qui permettent
d'instruire les hommes d'équipage et
vous allez tuer vous nous avez dit tout
à l'heure que au moment où vous avez été
sélectionné pour faire le vol apollo 11
il y avait à peu près une trentaine
d'astronautes vers l'iss était à peu
près 30 and astronautes capable de
prendre un départ puisqu'on préparé
plusieurs voiles à la fois qu'ils
avaient un équipage de ce coup et c'est
est ce qu'il y avait est ce qu'il ya un
gros un groupe avantage d'éliminer par
rapport à ceux qui sont retenus au
départ ceux qui sont finalement rejeté
ceux qui sont passés à travers le tamis
et bien non pas tellement non pas
tellement y ait eu relativement peu
qu'ils ont été éliminés brive où
j'estime que ceci est dû à la complexité
du procédé de sélection dans la plupart
des câbles en effet les éléments les
plus importants pour la sélection des
hommes d'équipage si la démonstration
qu'ils peuvent apporter de leurs
compétences dans les travaux et dans les
tâches précédentes et je m'explique
non pas ce qui pourrait fermer ce qu'ils
ont déjà fait tant dans le domaine du
val que dans le domaine scientifique et
ceux ci s'est avérée particulièrement
heureux comme méthode
ainsi par exemple il faut prouver que
l'on n'est pas costaud fab
c'est quelqu'un qui a été pilote d'avion
à réaction est évident qu'on ne se pose
pas cette question et on n'a pas à tenir
compte si vous voulez de ce genre de
cutter si bien que
tout cela a fort bien fonctionné
certains d'entre eux ont quitté les
préparatifs pour une raison ou une autre
parfois pour des raisons physiques
parfois parce que ils avaient d'autres
occasions qui leur était offert d'autres
possibilités de travail qu'il préférait
ou encore parce que l'entraînement ne
leur plaisait plus je crois savoir que
pour votre propre compte vous n'étiez
pas au moment où on est venu vous
chercher vous étiez pilote d'essai vous
pilotiez notamment le x-15 et vous
n'étiez pas convaincu parce que la nasa
préparez vous considériez que l'espace
c'était quelque chose de cassé nébuleux
finalement c'est exact c'est
partiellement vrai disons que ces
parcelles en vrai je m'intéressais quant
à moi aux préparatifs des vols spatiaux
avant spoutnik avec l'organisme qui a
précédé la nasa et qui est l anacs aena
ca et qui faisait la recherche
aéronautique surtout et bien nous avions
travaillé aux appareils et aux vols à
très haute altitude à très grande
vitesse alors qu'il n'était pas
populaire d'en parler à cette époque et
nous avons eu le sentiment à ce moment
là que un véhicule avec elle un appareil
capable de voler dans l'espace
constituerez le véhicule est la méthode
la plus adéquate pour conquérir l'espace
et puis s'est avéré par la suite que la
forme balistique la forme de d'apollo de
gemini ses formes que vous voyez sur ces
différentes maquettes celle ci par
exemple cette femme que voici en vue le
jour beaucoup plus rapidement et ont
fait leurs preuves plus rapidement et
elles ont donné d'excellents résultats
et bien maintenant nous voyons qu avec
la navette spatiale
l'appareil à elle revoit le jour et
peut-être que plus tard pour l'espace
nous ont des véhicules et alors
peut-être que ma toute première
hypothèse était assez bonne après
derrière vous là des maquettes de
laboratoire spatial du space lab
qu'est ce que vous pensez de ce projet
j'étais fort encouragé par le projet qui
m'a été montré également par
l'avancement des travaux concernant le
laboratoire spatial
je crois que la mise au point se fait de
façon parfaite tout se déroule
admirablement tout dépend bien sûr de la
disponibilité de la navette et la
navette vous le savez présente
actuellement certains problèmes
difficiles en matière de mise au point
il y à des retards dans la mise au point
technique et elles étaient censés voler
cette année ça ne se fera peut-être pas
et le projet va être retardée je crois
de de quelques mois ça se fera peut-être
à la fin de cette année peut être au
début de l'année prochaine
tout dépendra bien sûr de la vitesse
avec laquelle au pouvoir résoudre ces
problèmes techniques
toujours est il que je n'ai pas le
sentiment que ces difficultés
à propos de la navette sont
insurmontables
ce sont des problèmes d'ingénierie des
problèmes techniques qui requiert un
travail approfondi pour préparer la
navette et pour qu'elle soit fin prête
pour prendre son envol
et puis comme
nous pensons que il y aura les occupants
qui pourront s'occuper bien entendu du
laboratoire spatial c'est un projet
intéressant auquel on s'intéresse ici en
france ailleurs en europe je crois le
savoir et nous avons vraiment de très
grands espoirs
à ce propos et j'espère je ne sais
d'ailleurs que le travail sur 7 sur la
moto spatiale a été fort bien fait
appliquer les principes pour les
principales parties du du laboratoire
spatial vous pouvez le faire facilement
je vais vous aider vous avez des
problèmes de file voilà laboratoire
spatial a été créé en même temps que la
navette
ils les placer dans l'espace de
cargaison c'est une cale et ce n'est pas
la partie moindre de la navette
ils constituent les deux véhicules une
équipe en quelque sorte que l'on mettra
en orbite et les occupants qui sont
passés ici je ne sais pas si vous les
voyez bien d'ailleurs si vous voyez bien
cette partie de la maquette
oui on les voit très bien pourront au
cours du vol faire fonctionner les
différents appareils
innombrables qui ont été conçus très
précisément à ses fins pour ce
laboratoire spatial et ceux ci ont ce
module peut donc voler pendant la durée
que l'on voudra en même temps que la
navette et c'est la navette qui
déterminera la durée du vol
mais vous voyez un nouveau pas franchi
avec le laboratoire spatial par rapport
à ce qui a été fait jusqu'à présent
c'est un pas important
oui bien sûr bien sûr c'est un pas
important que nous accomplissons et cela
constitue en quelque sorte un progrès
dont le nom veut dans de nombreux
domaines
d'abord ça va être un des premiers vols
habités des vols spatiaux habités
accompli en collaboration avec les
européens
deuxièmement on se rend compte
maintenant très clairement ici en france
et ailleurs en europe
on se rend compte dis-je que cela
présenterait des avantages pour tous les
pays européens que ce genre de projet
que les investissements nécessaires à la
mise au point au fonctionnement encore
qu'ils soient importants seront
certainement moindre que les
investissements initiaux et que ce sera
rentable
on retrouve cette notion dont vous
parliez tout à l'heure de
supranationalité de l'association
mondiale universel sb oui cher d'abord
m'adresser aux téléspectateurs pour leur
dire et vous voyez que nous sommes
vraiment débordés par les fiches
qui n'est plus nécessaire de nous
téléphoner parce que nous n'arrivons
plus à lire toutes ces filles si elles
sont vraiment innombrables ce soir et
certains de nos correspondants monsieur
armstrong dit ce qu' il est tout à fait
naturel que vos compagnons et vous ayez
la vedette de cette aventure mais qu'il
convient quand même de rendre un hommage
à tous ceux qui sur terre on calculait
ont suivi ont dirigé cette opération et
voudrait savoir en gros quel rôle ils
ont joué oui vous l'avez dit d'ailleurs
tout à l'heure très très modestement
vous avez dit nous avons été les membres
de l'équipe est tout à fait normal que
nous ne soyons pas distinguer plus
particulièrement que d'autres citoyens
américains car il y avait derrière des
gens qui ont pensé des gens qui ont
réfléchi des gens qui vous ont aidé
pendant tout le vol à houston et alors
cette équipe-là a joué un rôle
extrêmement important peut-être
pardonnez-moi mais peut-être plus
important que le vôtre
oui oui je suis tout à fait un tout à
fait d'accord avec vous je tout à fait
d'accord pour dire que c'est leur tâche
qui était le plus important à quoi quand
même je faisais plus passionnantes à
faire mais c'est grâce à elle que tout a
pu se faire c'était une expérience
extraordinaire de travailler avec des
gens qui étaient tellement dévoué à leur
tâche
on peut dire que ils ont fait preuve
d'une créativité est une ingéniosité
extraordinaire à chaque instant tous les
amis auront ne savez jamais quand les
heures de travail avaient pris fin
pas parce qu'à 5 heures personne ne
rentrait chez lui chacun restait au
travail parce que ils avaient vraiment
envie de rester encore 1h 2h 3h
quelle que soit la tâche et chacun y
mettait du sien le faisait de bon coeur
et un fond de leur propre volonté
parfois il y passait des nuits entières
et c'est grâce à ça que ça marche et que
le projet a tourné il ya vu le jour et
ceci est vrai et mtv pendant dépendez
santé de milliers de personnes c'était
extraordinaire de travailler dans cette
ambiance dans une telle équipe est de
travailler avec des gens l'importance de
d'un nom qui est connue qui est
peut-être plus connu que les autres ici
en europe celui de werner von braun
quelle était l'importance de son rôle
von braun a très certainement joué un
rôle très important a été un rouage
important de la machine de la nasa
c'était un très grand technicien et
c'était un meneur d'hommes cet état à
l'homme d'organisation elle était
parfaitement incapable d'encourager les
gens de donner vraiment aux gens la
volonté de travailler et de de mener est
devenu une équipe c'est est certaine il
est certain que 75 que vous voyez là
aurait eu beaucoup de mal à voir le jour
sans avant bras
ça c'est absolument certain est sûre
l'équipe bien sûr c'était un très grand
homme lit d'abord il ya une question qui
revient très souvent et qui est posée la
plupart du temps par des pharmaciens ou
des médecins on nous demande si en cas
d'accident il avait quelque chose pour
ceux supprimés comme des capsule de
cyanure ou est ce que quelque chose
avait été prévu
non non
ah non il fallait toujours une date
étude positive envers les choses c'était
vraiment notre slogan fort positif du
talion même pas envisager une seconde
une telle issue de toute manière si
quelqu'un l'avait lavé souhaitait
c'était pas du tout notre cas c'était la
solution était très simple il s'agit
simplement de dépressurisée et c'était
tout aussi efficace que qu'une drogue
quelle qu'elle soit donc ce ne sont pas
les moyens qui manquait mais je peux
vous garantir que ces deux est jamais
passé par l'esprit avons toujours eu le
sentiment que nous allions de toute
manière réussie que ça allait marcher
et puis si une question se pose et au
sujet de sim question à problème se pose
et il s'agissait de la résoudre
c'était pas le scanner qui était la
solution soviétique avait préparé une
fusée qui était destiné allez vous
chercher également réduit des ennuis
je suis au courant de cela il est vrai
que d'apollo soviétique avait
effectivement un vaisseau non habité qui
s'appelait vu la lune un élu et qui
était temps aux gens érigent je devais
arriver
puis avant mais c'est immangeable
et s'il y avait autre chose de
disponible du côté soviétique j'avoue
que je n'ai pas entendu parler par
contre 7,7 en janvier tic dont vous
parlez a été lancée je crois sans que
les gens de la nasa ne le sache au début
et on a eu quelques inquiétudes pour
pour les la rencontre des deux orbites
et puis il ya une espèce de coopération
qui s'est faite entre la nasa et l'union
soviétique pour donner précisément le
calcul de leurs beats de l'argent
soviétique pour éviter qu'il y ait le
moindre problème
il y en a pas eu d'ailleurs mais il ya
eu là encore une coopération très très
près cinq jours et je vois que c'est
tout à fait exact
effectivement vous avez raison autre
chose oui on ne demandent également
quelle a été la réaction de madame
amstrong quand monsieur armstrong lui a
dit demain je pars pour la lune
j'ai la chance d'avoir une épouse avait
une famille qui soutenait mon action et
l'intérêt que je portais à l'émission ma
femme pour ça pas baba épousé lorsque
j'étais pilote d'essai par conséquent
elle savait à quoi s'en tenir
elle connaissait la nature de mes
activités dès le début la accepter cela
d'emblée au moment de notre mariage
alors je peux honnêtement dire je crois
qu'elle était tout aussi enthousiaste
que moi au sujet de cette chance que
j'avais de participer à la au projet
apollo autre chose oui la quarantaine
armstrong aldrin et collins ont dû subir
après leur retour sur terre est elle
absolument nécessaire savais que ça
après coup évidemment on peut se dire
non ce n'était pas nécessaire parce que
comme comme vous le savez elles l'avons
fait pour trois vols on a suivi la même
procédure et puis on s'est aperçu que
finalement non ne nions pas de germes
pathogènes sur terre qui pourrait un
danger sur terre cela étant dit la
décision il fallait la prendre
il fallait absolument suivre cette
procédure de quarantaine
même si la possibilité d'un film il
fallait quand même s'en protéger il
fallait protéger la population terrestre
entre une maladie qui aurait pu être
tout à fait catastrophique
et de toute manière je ne vous cache pas
que ça a été assez utile lors ce qui
nous concerne vous souviendrez que lors
de notre retour apollo 11
les gens étaient ils ont très
enthousiaste il y avait une sorte de
[Musique]
exactement auquel on l'a eu comme ce
soir
n'est ce pas les gens qui ont eu la
gentillesse de m'inviter à dîner et tout
ça est bien
de même lorsque le seul revenu sur terre
ne les tuera lci d'habitation du même
genre et cette période de quarantaine a
été fort utile pour nous parce que ça
nous a donné un petit peu le temps de
retrouver nos esprits et de faire la
chose la plus importante que nous avions
affaire qui était de de transmettre
toutes les informations aux l'équipage
du vol suivant il fallait absolument
leur dire tout ce que le savions et qui
pourraient être utiles pour leurs
propres vols
donc c'est à eux de 41 évidemment été
très utile enfin une fois c'est fait et
bien alain nous allons terminer
maintenant cette émission je dois dire
qu'il y a de très très nombreux
témoignages et messages d'amitié pour
monsieur armstrong des remerciements
très nombreux pour la visite qu'il a
bien voulu faire en france et sa
participation à cette émission
il faudrait trouver encore des centaines
de questions pour terminer cette
émission mais nous avons choisi avec
anne-marie l'amaury celle ci monsieur
armstrong
que ressentez-vous le soir lorsque vous
regardez la lune depuis votre maison
depuis la terre effectivement oui je
regarde la lune mais je vois à quelque
chose de différent par rapport à ce que
je voyais les avatars je vois maintenant
à à globe
je vois mais c'est assez pas simplement
des choses c'est un endroit c'est
important je suis allée ou où j'ai vu
reconnaîtrait des des paysages et alors
c'est un endroit où donc je suis allée
où il s'est passé des choses pour moi a
donc la lune mais devenu quelque chose
de très personnel mais la lune a quand
même gardé toute sa magie tous sont tous
son romantisme alors je c'est dommage
que nous soyons obligés de rester là
avec un si grand nombre de questions
restées sans réponse mais je voudrais
jeu jérôme saisir cette occasion pour
remercier les téléspectateurs pour tout
les jours gentil qui ont été dites à mon
égard je suis toujours très heureux de
devenir en france
au fil des ans je garde un souvenir très
très généreux je me souviens de manière
dont nous avons été reçus ma femme moi
même et mes coéquipiers lors de notre
visite
parce qu'il soit venu en france tout de
suite après apollo 11 je suis absolument
ravie d'être de nouveau ici et de vous
retrouver grâce à vous monsieur tron
puisque c'est l'heure des remerciements
sachez que les nôtres ont également très
sincère je crois pouvoir m'adresser à
vous en tant que représentant des
téléspectateurs guide arbois nous l'a
dit je voudrais également remercier au
nom de la chaîne en antenne 2 puis de
l'équipe des dossiers de l'écran d'être
venu ici ce soir dans cette salle
d'ailleurs que vous
vous aurez remarqué de votre présence
puisque nous sommes deux palais de la
découverte ce soir dans la salle qui est
dit de la lune d'ailleurs ce globe a été
fabriqué il ya fort longtemps on ne
savait pas que vous viendriez un jour et
je crois que vous avez très réellement
honorer notre émission honorer des
français ce soir en nous permettant de
commémorer ce que vous avez bien voulu
définir comme un événement non pas
seulement américains mais comme un
événement universel comme un événement
mondial pour toute l'humanité
ce rêve que tout homme a peut-être un
jour porté en son coeur celui de marché
sur la lune vous vous lavez réalisé et
vous nous avez permis ce soir à nous
français de dialoguer avec vous de
revivre ces instants par le film et par
votre bois et je voudrais que vous en
soyez très sincèrement remercier que
votre séjour ici en france sur les plus
heureux possible
bonsoir et merci pour votre prestation
c'était très difficile à faire vous
l'avez fait agresser au brio pour moi
c'est une grande joie
merci
[Musique]